good morning believe nation is it a good
idea to get a higher education we're
going to answer that question in today's
episode of believe life universities
definitely a very important if you're
learning science they're definitely very
important if you're learning you know
technology if you're if you want to be a
mathematician you know they play a big
role and you know the real question is
you know can they teach people
entrepreneurship or is it better that
people actually get out into the real
world and and then learn by you know
throwing themselves in the jungle and by
you know by the experience and we've and
we've actually encouraged this
government to actually come up with
entrepreneurial grants rather than just
student grants for people who've got
good business ideas and say you know get
you know let them get out get out into
the real world and try it
having said that I think there there
there is room for a really good in a
really good universities to to help help
people get on their feet who want to
become entrepreneurs and they they play
a very important role in particular for
those people who who won't necessarily
succeed in becoming an entrepreneur so
that they've got a a good a good
university education to fall back on but
the students around me were really
important as well right and both in high
school and in college I mean the people
who started Facebook with me and a lot
of people who are still with me running
the company today are people who I met
when I was at Harvard and some of them
were mighty ups at Harvard right and you
know when the professors were off
writing papers these were the people who
actually taught me and then we hung out
and we had like social bonds and
academic bonds and I just I wouldn't
understate the importance of that and I
mean it's very tied into my whole
and the product that I spend my life
building Facebook because we just
believe that social bonds are critical
through education
you can also better yourselves in other
ways you learn how to learn how to think
critically and find solutions to
unexpected challenges I remember we used
to ask our teachers why am I going to
need algebra well you may not have to
solve for X to get a good job or to be a
good parent
but you will need to think through tough
problems you'll need to think on your
feet you'll need to know how to gather
facts and evaluate information so math
teachers you can tell your students that
the president says they need algebra
education also teaches you the value of
discipline that the greatest rewards
come not from instant gratification but
from sustained effort and from hard work
there's a lesson that's especially true
today in a culture that prizes flash
over substance that tells us that the
goal in life is to be entertained that
says you can be famous just for being
famous may you get on a reality show
don't know what you've done suddenly
your fingers but that's not going to
lead to lasting sustained achievement
and finally with the right education
both at home and at school you can learn
how to be a better human being for when
you read a great story or you learn
about an important moment in history it
helps you imagine what it would be like
to walk in somebody else's shoes to know
their struggles the success of our
economy will depend on your skills but
the success of our community will depend
on your ability to follow the golden
rule
to treat others as you would like to be
treated whether you're getting an
education within the classroom whether
you're getting an education
experientially through doing it's
through that learning process that we
better understand our own skills our own
passions and learn more about what
opportunities are available to us the
world is changing so quickly our our
repository of information and knowledge
is evolving so quickly it's absolutely
critical to continue to learn continuous
education is no longer a luxury I think
one of the things that's wonderful about
the world that we live in today through
online and digital technologies are the
benefits of online education and so the
barriers to becoming better educated are
dropping in ways we've never seen before
so for those folks thinking about going
back to school and the importance of
going back to school in terms of
pursuing their their career ambitions
education is everything it's a
requirement if you're going to be able
to add value to this tech anomic world
that we live in you know pick the skills
that you believe are going to best suit
you in terms of your career ambition go
out and experience work within those
areas there's there's nothing like
getting real life experience identify
potential mentors and the people that
can share their learning with you
through their own previous experiences
and then put those educational
experiences to work and and see what's
working for you as an individual I think
trial and error is an enormous part of
the learning curve you know education
has never been about just the knowledge
being available if so and you want to
learn computer programming there's a
book by Don Knuth go buy a copy reading
one learn physics there's a book by
Richard Feynman go buy a copy read it
there's some reason that kids don't
learn that way very few you know just
sit down and read read the final book
you have to create a thing where there's
a social environment that encourages you
go when you get
confused those people help you out
all my life I've listened to people who
are in a position like I am on a couch
with an audience being able to speak
what we have to do to fix education
they've all been saying the same things
we've got to teach kids to think and not
just learn and not just memorize it all
these ideas and has education really
changed throughout my life our kids
really learning more than they could
have because of all this good intent no
the school system's the same it teaches
the same number of hours of the same
subjects that it always did the
approaches are very much the same as
ever and there's been no movement so I
don't think there's anything I could say
that would really change things
positively school in itself is pretty
much a restrictive force on creativity
school teaches you from the day that
you're in there that the right answer
when you come to class we do the exact
same thing just in the book the same
hours as everyone else in the class you
don't go off in your own little
directions in your own angles you don't
have that kind of autonomy and freedom
in school and you come in and you take
the test and you get compared to others
from day one and told who is good who is
not good by third grade the teachers
could easily spot the kids giving up on
education being important for life so
it's not and you're told you you want to
open that drawer I'm sorry it's a class
of 30 people I cannot manage you unless
you're all in your seats at the same
time so you're taught from day one don't
try to go off in a direction you think
of that is not conducive to the wave of
the future and your answers on the test
they better be the same as everybody
else in the class or you are not called
intelligent so if you tried to think of
something a different way why you know
two canoes aren't really gonna mean on
the river at this time because there's
wind you know if you tried to say
something like that you get the low
grade make it vibrate so schools are
really antithesis to creative thinking
maybe some day if you had one teacher on
one student you had 30 teachers at
opacity students point it would all get
individual attention they move it at
their own places so I think something a
computer could possibly be a teacher
computers today help with education but
they aren't teachers they aren't that
human element and I think we're getting
very close to we're building small
computers in the hand that have all the
sensors that a human has you know a
movement of eyesight of hearing I think
we're getting closer to where we can
make devices that become a friend and
not just a computerized textbook public
education is only a hundred and fifty
years old and we built it with a
specific function in mind we built the
educational system to train kids to sit
still long enough to work in a factory
that's what it's for to create compliant
obedient factory workers so the question
we need to ask is what is school for now
we're not asking that question parents
administrators
taxpayers are not asking the question
what is school for I have an opinion I
think what it's not for is to create
more factory workers because we don't
need more factory workers I think what
we need to do is teach kids two things
one how to solve interesting problems
and two how to lead and yet if you look
at just about any public school in North
America or Europe we're not teaching
that we're teaching kids how to do well
on the test instead it has never been
less valuable to be smart about
information than today the way we
educate our children right now so broken
it actually has zero valve professors
aren't relevant to a lot of their
students today more than ever which is
why it's insane what our children are
going through in the school system
making them memorize facts that aren't
there fingertips
most kids are learning more on their own
and than they are
who's the 19th president oh I don't know
this guy so many people have emailed me
like literally because of this show
emailed me that hey I'm in class right
now and what my professors talking about
makes no sense Internet is the biggest
culture shift in the history of human
beings when you're teaching our children
to memorize and I hope my children BDNF
students and that gives me time since
they're not gonna work on homework for
me to teach them the real and literally
professors in major universities that
are putting kids in debt right now are
telling them that there is no ROI in
social media like ludicrous horse crap
I'm so disgusted with what's going on
with universities across this country
there is a rolling and checking the
doubt going on in classrooms all across
this country and it's sad because of the
romance of how professors think it
should be versus the reality of what
it's like right now you know if you ask
who are the customers of Education the
customers of Education are the society
at large employers that hire people
write things like that but ultimately I
think the customers are the parents not
even the students with the parents the
problem that we have in this country is
that the customers went away the
customers stopped paying attention to
their schools for the most part well
what happened was is that mothers
started working and they didn't have
time to spend at PTA meetings and
watching their kids school schools
became much more institutionalized and
parents spent less and less and less
time involved in their kids education
and what happens when a customer goes
away and a monopoly gets control which
is what's happened in our country is
that the service level almost always
goes down
I remember seeing a bumper sticker when
the telephone company was all one AT&T
the Bell System
I remember seeing a bumper sticker with
the Bell logo on it and it said we don't
care we don't have to you know and
that's what a monopoly is that's what
IBM was in their day
that's certainly what the public school
system is they don't have to care now it
turns out what some go through some
economics the most expensive thing most
people buy in their lives is a house
second most expensive thing is a car
usually in a car cost average cars
approximately about $20,000 now 16
$20,000 and an average car lasts about
what eight years right you buy another
one so approximately you know $2,000 a
year right for eight year commitment
well your child goes to school right so
approximately eight years in K through 8
right
you don't like to switch schools it's
about an eight year commitment what is
the state of California spend per pupil
per year in a public school what they
spend per year per pupil is about forty
four hundred dollars okay about twice as
over twice as much as a car now it turns
out that when you go to buy a car you
have a lot of information available to
you to make a choice and you have a lot
of choices
I mean General Motors and Ford and
Toyota and Chrysler and Nissan they are
advertising at me like crazy I can't get
through a day without seeing five car
ads and they seem to be able to make
these cars efficiently enough that they
can afford to take some of my money and
advertise other people with it so that
everybody knows all about these cars and
they keep getting better and better and
better choices a lot of competition and
there's a warranty that's right but in
schools since people don't feel like
they're spending their own money they
feel like it's free right no one does
any comparison-shopping matter of fact
if you want to put your kid in a private
school you can't take the forty four
hundred dollars a year out of the public
school and use it you have to come up
with you know five or six thousand
dollars of your own or even forty four
hundred dollars of your own money I
believe very strongly that if the
country gave each parent
without your a check for $4,400 that
they could only spend at any accredited
school that several things would happen
number one schools would start marketing
themselves like crazy to parents to get
students secondly I think you see a lot
of new school starting I've suggested as
an example if you go to stand for
business school they have a public
policy track they could start a school
administrator track so you could get a
bunch of people coming out of college
tying up with something just got a
business school they could be starting
their own schools
you could have twenty five year old kids
out of college very idealistic full of
energy instead of starting a Silicon
Valley company they'd start a school and
I believe they would do far better than
many of our public school teachers do
the third thing you'd see is I believe
that you would see the quality of
schools again just like in a competitive
market start to rise some schools would
go broke a lot of the public schools
would go broke there's no question about
it would be rather painful for the first
several years and but I think far less
painful than the kids going through the
system as it is right now and some
people the biggest complaint is of
course that schools would pick off all
the good kids and all the bad kids would
be left to wallow together in either a
you know a private school or the
remnants of the public school to me
that's like saying well all the car
manufacturers are going to make BMWs and
Mercedes is and nobody's going to make a
$10,000 car well I think the most hotly
competitive market right now is the ten
thousand dollar car area you've got you
know all the Japanese playing in it
you've got General Motors that's spent
five billion dollars subsidizing Saturn
so far so that they can compete in that
market you've got Ford which has just
introduced two new cars in that market
you've got Chrysler with the neon so the
the market competition model seems to
indicate that where there is a need
there is a lot of providers willing to
tailor their products to fit that need
and a lot of competition which keeps
forcing them to get better and better
you know college tuitions have exploded
because of easy money guaranteed by
Salameh of student loans getting
guaranteed and so if any student can or
potential student can borrow more and
more money and it's guaranteed by the
federal government why wouldn't the
colleges take it all but the problem is
that bubble has led to over a trillion
dollars in student loan debt which is
having a significant impact on the
economy and it's really holding us back
in the economy's ability to grow it's
holding back housing it's holding back
apartment building it's holding back car
sales it's holding back clothing sales
you know any you know any type anything
that's not an absolute necessity kids
coming out of school today I can't spend
their money on and I think that's a real
problem for the economy and I think that
bubble is going to burst I think it's
inevitable at some point there'll be a
cap on student loan guarantees and when
that happens you're going to see a
repeat of what we saw in the housing
market when easy credit for buying or
flipping a house disappeared we saw a
collapse in the price of housing and
we're going to see that same collapse in
the price of student tuition and that's
going to lead to colleges going out of
business I read a very interesting
theory from you about if you are
graduating high school and you go to
college where your college still be in
business yeah at the end of four years
so pretend that you're talking to a
group of people at just about the
graduate from high school what's your
advice my advice to a junior or about to
be senior in high school is go to the
cheapest school possible to get your
freshman and maybe sophomore classes you
don't need to go to Harvard Harvard you
know introduction to writing and
freshman English and freshman sociology
okay you can make an argument it's gonna
be better than you know Joe Blow junior
college or Community College but the
reality is you have to weigh that
against if you're paying for your school
or more importantly if you're borrowing
money for your school do you want to be
saddled with 40 50 80 $100,000 in debt
I'll give up you know the incremental
value of freshman English at a great
school to not have the the stress you
know just physically on you
and your family and I think all that's
going to change like I went to Indiana I
loved Indiana I always recommend going
to Indiana are you hoo-hoo-hoo-hoo Jers
but the price for out-of-state has
gotten ridiculous and they want me to
build this building that only if your
school is building business building
buildings your school is [ __ ] but but
every school is building buildings
exactly that's my point of my post it's
like the newspaper industry write more
printing presses more big buildings
write makes this look grander we have
brains than we're putting them out there
there's there's a point of diminishing
returns in terms of what it's worth for
a college education and how much debt
you're willing to sound yourself with I
mean $40,000 in debt that's a shitload
of money
I don't want $40,000 in debt you know
it's just I think decision points have
got to be different schools have got
more administrators making over $200,000
a year than they have profs you know and
then the people that they're saying are
the greatest educators that you getting
you getting all your money's worth here
they're paying fifteen hundred two
thousand five thousand dollars a class
and those people have to have other jobs
and so there's just you and I both do
the same thing we look for industries
that are ripe for disruption because
they do things the way they've always
done them and I think universities
four-year universities are doing it and
and it's a real problem and so I told IU
that I will not do anything that
involves buildings and I've told other
you know universities and organizations
the same thing you know I'd rather see
you implode all those I mean they the
Sociology building the business building
the psychology building what's different
in any of the classrooms okay you got a
desk you got something the wall you got
you know audio-visual materials computer
Wi-Fi video conferencing whatever you
don't need a special building so you
know the psych professors can cuz they
have beards and they need two different
gloomy things in the bathrooms it just
makes no sense and so I think it's and
you combine that with easy money it's
easy to borrow money for school then you
have inflation you have school prices
that are run ramped up and it's going to
implode just like real
they did from easy money you probably
wouldn't fund the building a library huh
no now let's pretend that you're just
about to graduate from college right
what's the advice um you don't need the
perfect job you know part of the problem
is you probably have a hundred thousand
dollars of debt right you got a payoff
for all that [ __ ] and that's really
[ __ ] up it's hurt the economy it's
hard you it hurts everybody but um my
advice general advice is assuming
there's not just the bills you got to
pay that are just enormous if you paid
all that money to learn now here's your
chance to get paid to learn and you
don't need the perfect job you need to
get a job where you can make some money
but also where you can learn and add it
to your portfolio of knowledge added to
your foundation because as much as we
want to think that we know exactly what
our mission in life is and what our
chosen profession is going to be at 22
hell no there's just no chance that the
30 year old or even the 25 year old is
gonna look back at the 21 or 22 year old
you and say oh that - had it all
together and knew exactly what was up
right he's gonna look back and go beer
pong what were you thinking you know and
so it don't expect to have all the
answers and don't try to get the perfect
job go out there and get paid to have
different experiences and it's okay to
jump from job to job if it's not the
right job you are getting paid to learn
flip it and then use that to build your
knowledge and learn more about yourself
learn how to learn in business and see
where it can take you thank you so much
for watching it's a bit of a
controversial topic and I'd love your
feedback and thoughts on it leave it in
the comments below and I'm gonna join in
the discussion I made this video because
mohammadi Sakir asked me to so there's a
topic that you want me to cover in the
next edition of believe life leave it in
the comments below and I'll see what I
can do thank you for watching have an
amazing day continue to believe and I'll
see you soon